on this episode of snapchat spotify
engineer matt brown tells us how
kubernetes helps power the teams that
power Spotify increased deployments and
higher productivity are just the start
[Music]
thanks for trying to be Matt so how does
Spotify work when you use Spotify in
your laptop your mobile phone speaker in
your house if your app is connected to a
layer of services that we call the
perimeter series of gateways load
balancers things like that and then from
there depending on what you're doing in
the app you're connected to one of
hundreds or probably bout a thousand
different micro services that are
developed we used to run these all in
our own datacenter but over the years
we've moved fully to Google Cloud and
those micro services which are all
talking to each other are developed by
about 200 different teams within Spotify
and they're deploying those building
those independently based on one team
might work on a search feature the
playlist feature just different features
like that and then we have another group
of teams of infrastructure teams where
we're trying to build tools for those
teams to move faster do things in a
consistent way things like that so how
do you help those many many engineering
teams be able to focus on I'm going to
build this feature and then ship it
whether to staging or production and not
have to worry about all the
infrastructure so we do a lot as an
infrastructure team to try to make it
very simple to stand up a new service a
new feature there is a framework that
you can use basically gives you all the
basics of building a micro service
handling RPC calls logging connecting to
service discovery to find the other
services you need to talk to we also
make it very simple there's a single
button you can press in our developer
console to just create a new project new
source code repo and you get all that
stuff mentioned that I mentioned before
basically for free
you know just quote it from a template
so you're never really starting from
scratch and then you have to manage all
of these and figure out how they're
gonna actually stay alive or scale you
built your own system to do all that yes
we did so we started to adopt docker
it's inners very early on I think before
it was even version 1.0 and we were
really excited by it because it added a
bunch of new things that we didn't
really have great answers for a Spotify
at the time it used to be very painful
for teams to deploy changes to their
services
they'd frequently fail rolling back from
a failed deployment was pretty tricky
and as a result people teams just would
not deploy very often because there was
a lot of risk in payment that so we were
very interested in soccer because we
thought that building containers would
make it a lot simpler we could just have
deployments would be less a blur and if
you just want to roll back because each
container is kind of atomic totally
separated that it would be very simple
another big benefit is that it was just
a lot easier for elders to run the
service themselves on their laptop even
if it didn't really look like production
so the main reason we were super
interested in soccer to start with
wishes to make deploying easier making
running services easier and then to
increase the rate at which people were
deploying changes and just being
productive basically and is there
anything looking back on that at least
the first chunk of that transition that
you wish you did differently I would say
one thing that I wish we did a little
bit differently we were very conscious
as an infrastructure team that we're
changing out are basically the platform
that we were on applications on in
production which was working pretty fun
before it has some features that we wish
we had we they were missing that we wish
we had but if things weren't on fire or
anything like that so we wanted to be
very sure that what we move people to is
super stable they don't really notice
any problems and it's just all positives
for them to move I think as a part of
that we probably were a little hesitant
to take risks and we didn't want really
any team to move their service fully to
kubernetes until we were as a ever
stronger team a hundred and ten percent
prepare for that in retrospect I think
we could have accepted some more risk
the team the engineers on all of our
teams building these services they know
better than we do as an infrastructure
which services are super important which
services are internal facing and not
important at all and stance of downtime
so I think we could have let them take
some more risk and tell us what would be
you know like do some more experiments
themselves and we probably just learn a
few things a little bit faster are there
other things that you wish you did more
of as you're going through this
transition process I think one thing
that we found that kind of surprised us
as we did this is we didn't have to do
as much selling or evangelizing of the
rosy-cheeked aid to the engineering team
is that Spotify part of that's because
they just they dirty knew about
kubernetes again obviously is talked
about quite a lot in the development
community but also we found that some
early adopting teams were really happy
with the results and so they would go
out and talk to other teams and give
talks of like an internal conference
that we do or just they would try to
motivate their peers so I wish one thing
we could have done more of perhaps has
tried to take advantage of that create
more sort of champions internally
because I was rare of really those
engineers who did that work were really
the best selling point that we had for
convincing other teams to spend time
with us if you enjoyed this episode
check out the stack chat playlist for
more videos
you